afghan signé Solen chalvon fiority un
film choc un film coup de point et une
question centrale comment comment en
est-on arrivver là on va se poser cette
question avec nos invités cheekbaashemi
bienvenue à vous vous êtes présidente de
l'association Afghanistan libre
cofondatrice de stand speak rise up vous
êtes né à Kabul vous êtes arrivé en
France à l'âge de 11 ans première femme
afghane à avoir été diplomate auprès du
gouvernement provisoire après la chute
des talibans en 2001 et vous avez été
récompensé de multiples reprises pour
votre engagement Najat Valo Belkassem
bienvenue à vous également présidente de
France Terre d'Asile directrice France
de l'ONG one ancienne ministre des
Droits des FEM et ancienne ministre de
l'Éducation shakiba davode bienvenue à
vous également vous êtes comédienne
interprète artiste engagé membre du
collectif le bourri qui cour vous
militez pour que la France facilite la
délivrance de visas pour les femmes
afghanes en exil également présidente et
fondatrice de l'association Le Cercle
Peran et vous avez vous-même fu
l'Afghanistan il y a 15 ans Karim pxzad
bienvenue vous êtes chercheur associé à
l'IRIS institut de recherche
internationale et stratégique
spécialiste de l'Afghanistan de la Syrie
de l'Iran et de l'IRAC doctor enoit et
vous avez notamment enseigné les
sciences politiques à l'Université de
Kabou merci à tous les quatre d'être ici
je voudrais qu'on prenne d'abord le
temps de rester sur ce constat
absolument effrayant du film les
talibans semble-t-il cherchent à effacer
les femmes à les supprimer du paysage
che Keba chemi est-ce qu'on peut parler
d'un système de discrimination
sexiste institutionnalisé un système
comme il n'en existe pas ailleurs non
écoutez ce qui est intéressant aussi de
voir ce qu'on dit jamais depuis 2 ans
c'est que l'Afghanistan est le seul pays
au monde où par une loi écrite
l'éducation des filles est interdite on
se rend pas compte mais c'est quand même
voilà en 2023 ça existe et puis surtout
il y a 28 millions de femmes et petites
filles qui ont été enterrées vivantes du
jour au lendemain par ce même pouvoir à
qui on a donné quand même un peu la clé
le 15 août 2021 l'Occident en nous
faisant quand même avaler depuis 2 3 ans
en les appelant les talibans modérés en
N disant sur vos plateaux sur tous les
plateaux ici même nos politiques et
dirigeants que ce sont des gens avec qui
on peut négocier et que la condition des
femmes selon nos valeurs démocratiques
de l'Occident c'est une condition sur
lesquelles on va pas déroger aujourd'hui
on voit 2 ans après que ces femmes sont
muré vivantes elles n'existe tout
simplement pas et que on voilà on
aimerait bien nous euh les Afghans et
les Afghanes savoir ce qui est devenu de
toutes ces négociation et tous ces
accords qui ont été signés avec ces
terroristes qui pour nous on le savait
très bien c'est exactement la version 2
des talibans 962001 qui sont arrivés à
nouveau en 2000 le 15 août 2021 à
nouveau qui ont pris le Kabou on
approfondira la question de la
responsabilité potentielle du côté
occidental bien sûr restons peut-être
encore quelques minutes sur le constat
qui est fait par le film chakiba d'avode
on remarque les parcs leur sont
interdits les salles de sport leur sont
interdits les bains publics leur sont
interdits on se demande aujourd'hui ce
qu'il leurait autorisé ce qu'il leurit
permis est-ce que des choses sont encore
autorisées aux femmes en Afghanistan bon
c'est c'est une question qui est assez
clair à mon avis je pense que depuis
l'arrivée euh des taliban tout de suite
ils ont effacé le ministère des Affaires
des femmes par un milice qui s'appelle
euh la prévention de
euh vertu et promotion non prévention de
vice et promotion de vertuus euh et ils
ont effacé toute tout ce qui a été créé
par l'ancien gouvernement pour remplacer
euh enfin leur propre loi euh en ce qui
concerne les femmes et l'Afghanistan
c'est la seule enfin le seul pays dans
le monde où euh les jeunes filles euh et
les femmes n'ont pas le droit à avoir
des éducation secondaire ou aller à
l'université Karim pxzad on on essaie de
comprendre un petit peu la logique des
talibans est-ce que vous vous avez des
éléments d'explication il y a cette
femme cette militante très forte qui dit
à un moment donné dans le film euh en
quoi on est une menace pour eux
qu'est-ce qui les excite chez nous
comment ça se fait que nous sommes leur
cible est-ce que on a des éléments
d'explication quelle est la logique des
talibans derrière cela oui la logique
des taliban d'abord je dois être je dois
dire que je suis d'accord avec tout ce
qui a été dit avec une toute petite
nuance euh tout cela n'est pas interdit
par la loi euh pour une simple raison
que euh dans le régime B il y a pas de
Constitution il y a pas des lois ça
c'est pas un régime qui décrète des lois
qui a un conseil législatif et cetera et
cetera il y a pas de lo
l'origine de tout acte des
tban dans dans toutes les affaires de la
vie sociale politique économique et
cetera notamment la répression ou la
discrimination totale envers les femmes
a deux origines d'abord la en hm hm
ensuite euh les traditions ancestrales
euh d'une grande partie de la population
afghane notamment des taliban
c'est-à-dire les TR tradition ancêrale
dépachon c'est deux sources qui la
première est plus moin écrite parce que
c'est le Coran parce que c'est ad
c'est-à-dire les paroles de maoué ouord
de de mais le reste c'est décidé par les
hommes par les hommes et la 12e est
aussi important parfois même plus
important que la première Najad
alobelkassem que vous inspire la
situation de ces femmes vous avez parlé
tout à l'heure vous avez dit tout d'un
coup c'est vrai qu'il y a toute une
génération de jeunes femmes qui
n'avaient pas connu les talibans et qui
du jour au lendemain se retrouve soumise
à ces lois des taliban ça a été une
forme de sidération de choc absolu pour
ces jeunes femmes qui n'avaient pas
connu ça avant qui non seul seulement n'
avait pas connu ça avant mais qui avait
connu une période d'acalemie durant
laquelle elles ont montré beaucoup
d'appétten notamment pour les études
pour la scolarité et donc c'est vraiment
des espoirs qui sont plus que défit qui
sont détruits c'est une calamité
franchement nous alors je m'exprime ici
à la fois à titre personnel mais
évidemment aussi comme présidente de
France Terre d'Asile puisque France
Terre d'Asile mène un pladoyer assez
actif depuis maintenant plusieurs mois
pour que l'Union européenne la France
apporte des réponses au moins pour les
femmes qui cherchent à fuir parce que ce
qui a été décrit c'est encore j'allais
dire les mots sont trop faibles pour
décrire en murée vivante confiné à vie
aucune
perspective effacé on voit dans le film
ce moment où en plus victime d'attentats
divers et variés ne pouvant même pas
assister aux enterrements de de de des
leurs de leurs sœurs enfin c'est
vraiment une horreur absolue l'éducation
dans tout cela est un des éléments qui
nous frappe le plus parce que c'est vrai
que que voilà c'est quand même rarissime
de voir un pays comme ça et dictter une
telle règle euh mais au-delà de
l'éducation qu'est-ce qui se passe en
les empêchant de travailler nombre
d'entre elles étaient dans les métiers
du soin de la santé on va voir en fait
la santé aussi de ces femmes se dégrader
progressivement euh on voit l'extrême
pauvreté qui est remontée moi je dirige
une ONG one qui s'occupe de lutte contre
l'extrême pauvreté dans le monde donc je
peux vous dire ces chiffres là je les
suis aussi vous avez plus de 90 % de la
population aujourd'hui qui a du mal à se
procurer de quoi manger au quotidien
enfin c'est une catastrophe absolue
amnestie internationale a qualifié ce
qui est fait contre les femmes en
Afghanistan de CRIM contre l'humanité de
gnocide de gnocide et je pense que c'est
vraiment ça qu'il faut avoir en tête il
y a pas de pire pays aujourd'hui que
l'Afghanistan ou nêtre femme et et la
communauté internationale ne peut pas
rester comme ça sans réagir oui parce
que vous avez raison elles étaient dans
des métiers de soin est-ce que le régime
le pays peut tenir sans les femmes tout
simplement sans ce qu'elles faisaient
sans ce qu'elles apportaient au pays en
tant que femme qui travaillaient ce
qu'on oublie un peu c'est que avant
l'arrivée des talibans il y a eu 45
années de guerr et d'invasion
différentes en Afghanistan donc de par
ce fait entre les hommes qui ont fuit
les hommes qui ont été tués pendant ces
différentes guerres les hommes
handicapés plus de 75 % des foyers le
chef de famille étaiit des femmes
surtout dans les grandes villes donc
c'était son salaire qui nourrissait en
moyenne en estime à 5 enfants six
enfants par femme ce que nous avons
souvent avec shakiba au téléphone toutes
ces femmes afghanes qu'on essaie d'aider
et cetera c'est cette question moi qui
me terrifie dès que j'allume mon
téléphone c'est pourquoi ce silence
comment ça se fait que vous le savez de
l'autre côté et que vous ne bougez pas
pourquoi nous entirrez vivantes 28
millions sans qu'il y ait aucun aucune
réaction on a des films comme celui-là
qui nous exp ch sa après c'est vrai que
moi j'aurais bien voulu qu'il y ait des
politiciens qui nous parlent moi il y a
quelques jours je me suis retrouvée avec
Monsieur ludriant l'ancien ministre
d'affaires étrangères qui était sur les
plateaux de télé en 2000 2020 qui nous
disait taliban inclusif modéré et cetera
et il a répondu totalement à côté de ma
question quand je l'ai interpellé sur le
le le fait que ils sont ou vos taliban
modéré voilà qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
mais parce que tout le monde est très
très gêné vous savez la plupart du temps
quand vous parlez des femmes afghanes
les politiciens ont un petit regard vers
le bas donc on aimerait bien que ce
regard se lève et qu'on comprenne ce qui
se passe et moi ce dont j'ai très peur
c'est que non seulement le terme
génoucide ça nous parle pas aujourd'hui
et cetera ce qu'on oublie aussi c'est
que c'est terrible ce qui se passe pour
les femmes afghanes le pays le pire pour
les femmes aujourd'hui c'est que ça nous
concerne aussi ici en Occident cette
crise afghane c'est qu'aujourd'hui c'est
devenu aussi le laboratoire de
fabrication de terroristes et si demain
on recommence tout ce que nous avons
vécu en Occident à ce momentlà on verra
qu'il y a 28 millions de femmes qu'on a
enterré vivantes et à la différence de
96 où les talibans première versions
sont arrivées c'est qu'en 2021 on le
sait tous tout le monde le savait donc
on a tous une responsabilité il y a
aussi une question qui m'a frappé dans
ce film elle est un tout petit peu
abordée c'est la question de la santé
mentale des femmes on a cette jeune
femme qui est qui qui semble être en
dépression le sujet est pris au sérieux
par les experts des droits humains de
l'ONU qui sont allés sur place en mai
dernier nous sommes alarmés par les
récits de suicide croissant chez les
femmes et les filles disent--il il y a
pas de chiffre officiel évidemment il y
a pas de chiffre précis mais il y a une
enquête qui a été menée sur un/3 des 34
provinces du pays jusqu'en août 2022 et
elle montre que les femmes sont
désormais plus nombreuses que les hommes
à tenter de se suicider on est en train
de mettre à mort les femmes
d'Afghanistan il y a pas d'autrees nom
c'est ce que nous dit la présidente
d'ONU femme France est-ce qu'on a une
idée du niveau de ce fléo de ces
suicides de ces questions de santé
mentale en Afghanistan est-ce que vous
en avez une idée est-ce qu'on on le sait
par le nombre de boîtes d'antidépresseur
qui circulent par est-ce qu'on a des des
éléments qui nous disent quelque chose
de la santé mentale des femmes
afghanes moi je pense que les femmes
afghanes sont très fortes elles ont
montré en fait dès l'arrivée des
talibans à quel point elles sont
résilientes et et qu'elles sont prêtes à
se battre pour leur liberté
euh je pense que ça c'est une partie
enfin de de ce qu'on peut voir
évidemment la guerre c'est c'est pas
quelque chose d'enchantant enfin tout le
monde est triste personne n'a envie
qu'il y ait toujours des crises euh
évidemment il y a des femmes qui
souffrent les femmes afriganes depuis
plusieurs générations sont en train de
ramasser les roliques de leurs enfants
elles donnent elles sont devenus une
machine de reproduction des êtres
humains et la guerre leur dév en fait
leurs enfants et euh voilà les femmes
euh de cette nouvelle génération des
femmes afghanes euh ne sont pas les
mêmes que l'ancienne génération elles
sont éduquées elles savent mieux s'en
sortir et donc combative oui combattive
il y avait beaucoup de femmes
entrepreneures justement qui qui ont
créé des
entreprises combien même qu'il y ait
autant de difficultés les femmes
continuent à se battre même si ils sont
derrière le enfin euh les rideaux enfin
dans le
frontp SU chez les très jeunes chez les
très jeunes chez les très jeunes les
mamans nous disent que certaines avaient
c'est pour ça qu'elles étaient debout
encore elles sont encore debout
aujourd'hui vous savez il il y a quand
même des les femmes résistantes même si
sur les quatre qui manifestent il y en a
deux qui rentrent pas chez elle le soir
parce qu'elle sait que elle risque leurs
vie elles sont quand même debout mais il
a eu beaucoup beaucoup de suicide nous
nous avons beaucoup de cas de suicide
chez les très jeunes qui ont tout d'un
coup comme vous le disais si bien tout à
l'heure ne connaissez pas ce régime vous
dit très jeune c'est moins de 20 ans
c'est moins de 20 ans c'est toutes
celles que tout à l'heure vous parlez de
toutes celles qui ont eu cette fenêtre
d'espoir pendant 20 ans éduqué apprendre
l'anglais le français aller travailler
prendre des cours de langue et cetera
faire du sport dans les grandes villes
en tout cas donc les grandes campagnes
c'est autre chose c'est un autre débat
mais chez les tous c très jeunes et dans
les grandes villes et c'est pas des
comprimés on a pas de comprimé hein
c'est imolation c'est se brûler c'est
des choses beaucoup plus terrible que
des comprimés on a pas de médicaments en
Afghanistan donc c'est euh oui je suis
d'accord
d'une manière générale tout ce que vous
dites euh mais quand même il faudrait un
peu relativiser relativisé dans quel
sens dans ce sens que par exemple un ti
d'exemple euh dépression des femmes euh
suicide chez les femmes c'est pas
nouveau h c'est pas nouveau en
Afghanistan c'est pas nouveau par
rapport au 15 a 202 mais c'est pas une
raison de l'accepter non non bien c'est
pour ça que je dis que je suis d'accord
avec vous surtous ces élémentsl mais
quand même il faudrait que lestoes
sache tout ça c'est nouveau n'est pas
nouveau d'ord parce que c'est un système
très patriar patri voilà la raison la
raison et même avant si on a on avait
pas vraiment des chiffres euh des
éléments concrets pour pour savoir
combien des femmes on sont suicidé mais
on le sait moi je le sais moi je le sais
de fait de mon origine de fait de mon
âge de de de fait de d'avoir connu
différents régimes en Afghanistan c'est
que les femmes ont toujours été
réprimées discriminées et les femmes
non je vais tout de suite mettre en part
une toute petite minorité éduquée formé
onit des études avec une différence
ville et campagne ou pas Karim
pzad y a une énorme différence n valass
non je voudrais revenir juste sur cette
question du suicide parce que en
précisant une chose pour la bonne
compréhension de tout le monde c'est que
ces chiffres du nombre de femmes qui
finit par être supérieur à celui des
hommes en suicide euh sont
particulièrement frappants parce qu'à
l'échelle mondiale on sait que
généralement le nombre d'hommes est
toujours largement plus important que le
nombre de femmes euh devant le suicide
suici et donc quand cette ce rapport là
s'inverse mais ça nous renseigne
évidemment de façon absolument flagrante
sur ce qui se passe dans ce pays et la
deuxième chose que je voulais dire c'est
que les femmes afghanes qui se suicident
c'est en Afghanistan c'est
malheureusement aussi au Pakistan par
exemple parce que on peut pas ne pas
évoquer ce qui se passe en ce moment les
quelques femmes afghanes qui arrivent à
quitter
l'Afghanistan pour essayer de se
réfugier arrive soit en Iran soit au
Pakistan dans les pays voisins et il se
trouve que le Pakistan récemment pris
d'un coup de colère contre son voisin
afghan a décidé qu'il allait chasser 2
millions de réfugiés afghans aller chez
lui et donc du coup ces femmes parmi
elles parmi ces personnes ces femmes qui
ont compris que elles allaient être
obligées de retourner dans leur payé
elles sont très nombreuses à se suicider
en ce moment même au Pakistan et en Iran
pareil et en Iran pareil préfère mourir
que de revenir exactement donc enfin je
veux dire ça plaide encore une fois pour
que quand ces femmes ont réussi à
quitter leur pays et rejoindre un pays
voisin nos autorités consulaire sur
place les aideent à si possible
rejoindre la France ou l'Europe
l'histoire de l'Afghanistan est
intimement liée à la la nôre à celle des
occidentaux le film Le raconte très bien
au lendemain des attentats du 11
septembre 2001 à New York les États-Unis
soutenus par l'OTAN déclenche une
nouvelle guerre et renverse le régime
taliban l'objectif initial était de
faire en sorte que le pays ne soit plus
une base pour les terroristes ça a duré
20 ans 20 ans de présence internationale
sur le sol afghan 20 ans de protection
relative des femmes afghanes la
réalisatrice parle même et vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure d'une phase
d'émancipation pour les femmes afghanes
et un jour tout le monde a décidé de
partir abandon trahison aux yeux de
certaines femmes afghanes qu'on entend
dans ce film écoutez je dirais que la
coalition internationale n'en avait
sincèrement rien à des femmes en
Afghanistan
ou les petites femmes d'Afghanistan
elles ont des problèmes allons les aider
vite et puis quand elle n'a plus eu
besoin des mêmes femmes afghan dans sa
stratégie alors elle les a
lâché najkassem j'ai envie d'interroger
l'ancienne ministre que vous êtes vous
êtes du côté du pouvoir un peu plus que
nous tous ici réunis est-ce que vous
avez le sentiment que la coalition
internationale que les Occidentaux ont
abandonné les femmes afghanes elles les
ont ils les ont lâché
euh d'e certaine façon oui ouais je je
suis bien obligée de le de le dire parce
que vous voyez par exemple quand en août
2021 donc que Kabou est tombé il y a eu
un certain nombre de départs comme vous
le savez y compris ici en France a été
organisée une opération qu'on appelle
l'opération apagan pour rapatrier on va
dire le maximum de gens de personnes
afghanes qui avaient notamment aidé nos
forces sur place euh c'est étonnant tout
de même que à ce moment-là on se soit
pas dit mais en fait c'est
essentiellement des hommes c'est ça euh
en fait bien s en réalité quand vous
regardez les demandeurs d'asile afghans
sur notre territoir il y en a peut-être
je sais pas 10000 en ce moment et bien
ce sont pour la quasi totalité ce sont
on des hommes parce que qui sa qui a
réussi à fuir sans avoir besoin d'un
chaperon pour prendre je sais pas quoi
l'avion au moment de d'Out
2021 sans les enfants à traîner ou alors
à faire le périple enfin qu'on imagine
bien par l'Iran la Turquie et cetera au
risque d'être victime de traite torturé
ou que sais-je qui fait ça donc c'est
plutôt les hommes que les femmes donc en
fait que la communauté internationale à
ce moment-là avec la coalition ce soit
pas dit ben en fait les femmes il va
falloir qu'on aille les chercher euh les
hommes ont peut-être réussi à arriver
par leurs propres moyens les femes il
faut qu'on aille et ça veut dire quoi
aller les chercher ça veut dire créer
des corridors humanitaires ça veut dire
faciliter la délivrance de visa on a
plus faut comprendre que la France n'a
plus de représentation consulaire en
Afghanistan d'accord donc c'est pour ça
que on s'intéresse de si près à ce qui
se passe dans les deux pays voisins donc
Pakistan et Iran et qu'on dit quand les
femmes elles sont rares malheureusement
mais les quelques femmes qui arrivent à
fuir l'Afghanistan pour aller dans un de
ses pays voisins où on a des
représentations consulaires des
ambassades il faut sur place leur
délivrer des visas rapidement en
comprenant que les démarches elles
peuvent pas prendre des mois et des mois
en comprenant que leur gouvernement
afghan ne leur délivre plus de passeport
donc c'est pas la peine de leur demander
de fournir un passeport ou de retourner
chez elle pour avoir le bon papier enfin
c'est vraiment impossible donc il faut
vraiment les aider ne rien comprendre à
ce qu'elles vivent il faut aussi avoir
en tête que quand elles AR arrive dans
un de ces pays Pakistan Iran euh
franchement c'est des gouvernements qui
les aident pas beaucoup sur place hein
donc elle se retrouve souvent à la rue
complètement démuni victime évidemment
de violence sexuelle pour certaines même
obligé de se prostituer enfin c'est
c'est c'est c'est une horreur tout tout
est une horreur dans l'histoire donc
nous autres si on a un peu de valeur
qu'on se dit diplomatie féministe et
cetera franchement ne pas agir là-dessus
en délivrant des visas et en créant ce
corridor humanitaire c'est
incompréhensible shakiba Davot vous les
entendez ces mots d'abandon de trahison
de la part des femmes afghanes avec
lesquelles vous êtes en contact elles se
sonent abandonnées par l'Occident par
les forces occidentales oui bien bien
sûr bien sûr enfin je je suis
complètement d'accord avec ce que dit
Nadia je pense que quand on a
évacué enfin le 15 août 2021 des Afghans
la plus part d'entre eux c'était des
hommes et après les femmes qui les
accompagnaient étaient des mères mais
pas forcément des militants des
journalistes activistes de droits de
l'homme en fait les enfin il y a un
grand nombre des femmes éduqué activiste
en tout cas Activ socialement ont resté
en Afghanistan ne pouvait pas sortir et
les élites avaient déjà évacué
l'Afghanistan avant le 15 août ils
étaient sorti enfin dans les pays
étrangères ou même arrivé en France un
mois avant la chute parce que tout le
monde avait prévu en fait l'Occident les
États-Unis ceux qui ont signé les
accords de DOA ils savaient très bien
que avec l'arrivée de l'Afghanistan cet
effondrement va avoir lieu tel que ça a
eu lieu exactement SAF les femmes
afghanes c'était les premières surprises
c'est-à-dire que elles comprennent
toujours pas aujourd'hui que le 15 août
2021 on donne la clé à un régime et elle
pensait que justement nous avalit ces
négociations et que jamais on allait
toucher au moins au minimum le droit au
travail à l'éducation c'était les
premières surpris imaginaent elles
imaginait et qu'est-ce qu'elles
imaginent peut-être encore qu'on
intervienne à nouveau est-ce que c'est
ça qu'il faudrait que que la coalition
une autre coalition internationale pay é
intervi c'estàd que le but là on va pas
refaire le débat pour savoir s'il faut à
nouveau une force militaire et cetera
c'est ce qu'ell comprennent pas et on
est là moi je suis là en tout cas pour
pas aussi apporter la parole de ces
femmesl ce qu'ell comprennent pas c'est
comment c'est possible bah par exemple
j'aimerais beaucoup qu'elles entendent
le discours de de nadad valkassem c'estd
comment c'est possible que l'Occident
qui était là pendant 20 ans et que le
but c'était de dire on vient vous aider
parce que vous êtes battu contre le
terrorisme international il faut quand
même rappeler qu'on est venu en
Afghanistan parce qu'il y a eu le 11
septembre 2001 pas pour les femmes
afghanes on est venu parce que voilà et
donc pendant cette période làà 20 ans
leur a dit on est là on a été eu des
femmes comme moi diplomates et cetera et
on s'est battu on a présenté l'Occident
on a même formé on les a for moi-même
j'ai poussé des centaines de femmes en
disant il faut te montrer il faut créer
ton association il faut faire des pages
facebook il faut être active et toutes
celles-là j'ai du mal à leur répondre
aujourd'hui en disant puisque tu as fait
tout ça et que tu connais l'Occident et
que tu es aussi de l'autre côté comment
ça se fait que ce silence sassordissant
et en fait c'est ça la réponse vous
savez moi j'ai une silence et non action
et mais c'est surtout le silence
c'est-à-dire que on fait quoi en fait en
muré vivant donc pour reond dire à ce
qui a été dit moi j'ai je me suis occupé
pendant 30 ans d'une ONG française qui
s'appelle Afghanistan libre on a 300000
filles qui allaient à l'école
aujourd'hui on a aucune de nos écoles
qui peut fonctionner le directeur la
directrice on été emprisonné pendant 3
mois j'étais obligé d'Inter venir par
des choses dont je suis pas très fière
pour pouvoir les sortir de là-bas sans
qu'elle soit lapidée sans qu'elle soit
tuée parce que bah c'est-à-dire que on a
on a bien évidemment c'est-à-dire que on
sait très bien quels sont les pouvoirs
qui aident j'étais obligé de faire
intervenir des amis qui étaient à DOA
pour il des pouvoir des gens qui sont au
pouvoir que je connais qu' devait
intervenir par DOA qui a reçu des coups
de fil de Kabou pour dire il faut
libérer et cetera alors
que jeudi soir elles ont été libérées
alors que le vendredi c'était il fallait
leur seul leur seul défaut c'était
qu'elles étaient directrices de nos
écoles hein donc ces écoles n'existent
pas et aujourd'hui Afghanistan libre c
que j'avais est en il y a il y a un
décret des talibans du ministère des
Affaires étrangères de Kabou en disant
ça ne doit pas exister aucune école ne
doit fonctionner ce sont des mécréantes
ce qui me mémorifie le plus moi
aujourd'hui vous savez c'est quand
pendant 2019- 2021 je venais sur les
plateaux parce que je disais ça n'existe
pas de taliban modéré il faut arrêtez de
nous dire ça vous avz averti hein vous
négociez avec eux aujourd'hui on dit bah
non on peut pas discuter avec ce régime
donc on fait pas de l'aide humanitaire
donc je comprends plus
rienandne aband entre négociation et
discussion si moi je comprends pas de ce
côté avec vous comment comprennent ces
afghan les 28 millions de femmes comme
vous dites NON action quoi voilà
abandonné abandonné lorsque les Afghans
disent oui vous faites vous ne faites
rien vousz vous nous avez abandonné ou
il parle pas il parle pas de l'
humanitaire il parle pas de visa de quoi
parle alors ils ne savent pas au même de
quoi ils parlent parce que si il parl
encore d'une nouvelle invasion
d'Afghanistan par une puissance
étrangère pour libérer entre guillemets
pour libérer l'Afghanistan on va
assister encore à la même ch c'est la
raison pour laquelle c'est la raison
pour laquelle il faudrait à mon avis moi
je dis que l'Afghanistan a été abandonné
voilà l'Afghanistan a été abandonné non
non seulement abandonné euh pour si on
prend prend le point de bu des Afghans
mais il a abandonné l' enfin la communé
internationale vous savez lorsquon parle
de la communauté internationale
c'està-dire les pays occidentaux alors
cette communauté internationale a
abandonné Afghanistan aux puissances
régionales h Afghanistan des tban St
quasiment enfin de facto euh tacitement
et reconnu par la Chine par la Russie
par l'Iran par l'oubékistan par par par
paristan ex reconnu quasiment
euh voilà donc
voilàant bon d'accord Trump don le Trump
qui vous revenir au pouvoir il a annoncé
hier que moi je vais faire des affaires
avec les
toband aux échanges je demande de me
redonner la base militaire de de Bagram
à part des déclarations de ce genendre
moi je ne pense je pense qu'il faudrait
voilà il faudrait chercher une solution
à l'intérieur du pays parce queil
n'existe pas
malheureusement il n'existe pas si vous
voulez la solution ne viendra pas de
l'extérieur c'est ce que vous nous dites
c'est une question POS et c'est le sens
du du deuxème extrait que que je vais
diffuser maintenant est-ce que le
changement peut et va venir de
l'intérieur est-ce qu'il peut venir par
exemple de ce courage incroyable de ces
femmes afghanes qui résistent je
voudrais qu'on écoute cette femme qui
résiste justement en
Afghanistan mais je suis prête à tout à
tout types d'incident je suis même prête
à ce qu'un homme armé vienne ici et me
tire une balle sur cette chaise je suis
prête pour ça et j'en suis
heureuse la mort nous accompagne nous
les humains on va tous mourir
aujourd'hui ou demain alors pourquoi ne
pas vivre nos vies avec dignité pourquoi
ne pas vivre avec fierté
si je meurs demain je mourrais fier
d'être resté avec les femmes
d'Afghanistan jusqu'au dernier jour de
ma
vie est-ce que la solution peut venir de
là de ce courage de ces femmes et
peut-être aidé par des hommes on n' pas
parlé des hommes mais est-ce qu'il
résiste au côté de ces femmes par
exemple moi je voudrais revenir à au
début de notre débat c'est-à-dire qu'on
est là pour les afghan et c'est vrai
pour un
Afghanistan avec des solutions certes
mais il faudra savoir aussi que ces
accords de DOA pour mettre ses talibans
au pouvoir ont été décidés sans les
Afghans avec justement l'Occident et à
DOA c'était pas décidé en Afghanistan
avec les Afghans et dans le pays ça a
été décidé à l'extérieur donc arrêtons
l'hypocrisie aussi de se dire que les
solutions va venir d'un pays qui a été
détruit pendant 45 années avec quatre
invahisseurs différents à commencé par
les Russes et que dans ça peut pas venir
de l'intérieur ça ne peut pas venir dire
que les talibans sont pas de l'Intérieur
déjà les talibans Jalalabad prennent
leurs instructions auprès de Pakistan
les les talibans de Kandar prennent
leurs instructions auprès de DOA les
talibans de Kabul prennent leurs
instructions auprès des des autres pays
et il y a l'ingérence de tout le monde
et en plus on le sait très bien que en
août 2021 la négociation a été faite au
niveau régional en dehors des Afghans
pour dire on vous laisse l'Afghanistan
au russes au chinois parce qu'il y avait
ce projet de route de la soie avec 50
milliards d'investissement et qu'en
échange on va se concentrer sur l'Asie
du Sud-Est on oublie aussi que le le 15
août 2021 par exemple camala Haris
c'était à Singapour alors qu'il y a eu
la prise de Kabul donc bien évidemment
que la solution doit venir de
l'intérieur et bien évidemment mais sauf
que nous parlons d'un pays le moins
avancé du monde aujourd'hui avec pas 15
millions mais les chiffres du PAM c'est
plus de 29 millions qui ne mange pas à
sa fin et avec 45 années de guerre et la
destruction totale de l'État quatre fois
de différent donc comment voulez-vous
qu'avec ça c'est ça la grande différence
par exemple entre les Afghanes et les
Iraniennes vous savez en Iran
l'éducation n'a jamais été interdite
hesiversitéilà en afanistan nousons pas
alors CT il faut pas que tout le monde
fu parce que voilà mais c'est facile à
dire pour moi qui suis ici du bon côté
de la planète mais pour celles qui sont
là-bas la solution vient aussi parce que
il faut des coups de main il faut des
des gens comm nous de l'extérieur qui
les
abandass il y a eu cet appel en France
de 350 personnalités pour multiplier les
visas pour les femmes afghanes est-ce
que les solutions peuvent venir et
doivent venir de l'extérieur ou est-ce
qu'elles doivent aussi venir de
l'intérieur est-ce que c'est même
possible apparemment ça allit pas alors
on a lancé cet appel notamment avec
Solen chadon fiorti parce que on avait
quand je dis on sa France Terre d'Asile
parce que on avait vraiment besoin que
le gouvernement entendre que il y avait
une mobilisation de la société civile et
pas simplement d'une association d'une
journaliste et cetera c'est quelque
chose qui nous touche toutes
particulièrement les femmes mais aussi
les hommes et je crois que ça a été
compris il y a eu de nombreuses réunion
union au sein du gouvernement pour de
l'Élysée pour travailler sur le dossier
je suis pas du tout satisfaite de la
façon dont ça a avancé d'cord pour être
tout à fait franche quand en septembre
dernier on a accueilli à grand renfort
de communication je crois qu'il va y
avoir cinq femmes afghanes à l'aéroport
en disant bravo on les accueille enfin
c'est pas possible quoi il faut être à
la hauteur de de l'enjeu euh parce que
je suis quand même bien d'accord avec
une chose c'est qu'il faut distinguer
l'enjeu diplomatique et l'enjeu
individuel enjeu diplomatique
c'est-à-dire comment est-ce qu'on peut
faire changer le les talibans si
quelqu'un peut le faireeviendrait dans
un instant mais l'enjeu individuel c'est
que pendant ce temps-là il y a des gens
qui meurent il y a des femmes qui sont
en muré vivantes et cetera et bon voilà
individuellement vous pouvez leur tenir
tous les discours que vous voulez le
plus urgent c'est quand même de les
aider à à s'en sortir ce qui passe
aujourd'hui
s
VI mais pour revenir à l'enjeu
diplomatique plusieurs choses d'abord
euh
je je sais pas ce qu'en pense mes mes
mes collègues autour de la table mais
euh euh moi j'ai jamais imaginer que les
gouvernements occidentaux auraient un
quelconque levier d'influence sur les
talibans puisque les talibans par
définition arrive au pouvoir contre les
gouvernements occidentaux donc je
j'imaginais mal comment est-ce que je
pas les États-Unis ou quiconque de ce
côté-là de la de la Terre pourrait peser
sur eux en revanche on aurait pu
imaginer notamment du fait des liens
vient de rappeler chez Keba avec le
Qatar et cetera que des gouvernements
arabes puissent peser ou chercher
influencer disons euou que cette VI
adoucir un petit peu les positions des
talibans je n'ai rien vu de tel et et
c'est désespérant fait ouais c'est ça
mais peut-être qu'on peut terminer ce
tour de table cette émission parce
qu'elle arrive à sa fin sur cette
question là est-ce que ça pourrait venir
des des des pays arabes Karim
pzad le problème est que les trand ce
sont B des gens afro hein on le connaît
leur pratique leur façon de Vire leurs
croyances je suis pari en je suis
parmi ceux qui ont lutté combattu les
tandes
depuis la fin des années 90 vous voyez
mais en même temps oui en même temps je
connais l'afghanissan même ces dernières
années je suis allé CIN fois en N jamais
gagneré cette guerre militairement
d'accord pourquoi je pensais ça parce
que je connaissais l'Afghanistan je
savais que malgré ce que qui vient de
dire c'est très à la mode surtout pour
une partie de la population ou plutôt
pour une partie de des forces politiques
de dire que les tban sont des serviteurs
de Pakistan voilà ben non ce n'est pas
vrai ils sont indépendants vous dire
aujourd'hui le Pay pays lequel ils sont
en conflit aujourd'hui c'est le Pakistan
justement non lement malheureusement ils
ont une asscis ethnique on appelle en
France assis populaire qu'on Afghanistan
une asscis populaire se traduit par la
Suiss ethnique forcément parce que c'est
un pays multiethnique chaque personne
chaque politicien chaque parti l il
parle de le racisme il parle de
influence qu'il a au sein de son éthnie
voà c'est comme ça et les Parlement
malheureusement il représente une force
énorme dans le passé et aujourd'hui
militairement grâce aux États-Unis 2
secondes je vous donner une secondes par
les Américains ont
laissé
360000 mitraillettes
M4
360000 m la France la France pour
renouveler ses mitraillett de son armée
à commandé
120000 la proportion vous
voyez
l'ement possède
2000 Blandé 60
chares c'est ça notre politique la
question alors on si on vous faire
intervenir bon on va répéter je pense pe
venir l'espoir alors je pense que il
faut être naïf de vouloir seulement
attendre aux femmes afcanes de changer
la situation de résister et ceter
d'accord
je engager les hommes afans pourquoi on
attend tout le temps que les femmes fent
des efforts mais on attend rien des des
afgans tout simplement enfin il y a
quelques jours il y avait un chef de
gouvernement taliban abdulbi
Ouar le directeur voilà le directeur de
bureau dealimentation et de médicaments
taliban sont est venu en Allemagne pour
assister à une conférence parmi leurs
fidèles et mais avant ça avant d'aller
en en Cologne
att avant avant ça en fait il était en
voyage en Belgique en au Pays-Bas au
Pays-Bas et en Slovaquie comment un
représentant taliban peut circuler dans
les pays enfin en Occident comme ça si
librement et participer à des réunions
tout simplement dès leur arrivée on a
dit on on ne négocie pas avec les
talibans alors qu'est-ce que c'est alors
que quand ils ont des voyages
diplomatiques en il voyage très
facilement alors que de l'autre côté les
femmes afghanes enfin V manifestai dans
la rue pour essayer de soutenir leur
leurs sœurs en Afghanistan et que nous
de l'autre côté on a un grande diaspora
afghan notamment des hommes qui soutient
les talibans et ils sont pas seulement
en Allemagne ils sont en France ils sont
partout et nous n'arrivons pas à cadrer
et engager ces personneslà à utiliser
leur force pour de les caler de bon côté
de voilà B un appel est lancé en tout
cas plusieurs appels même sont lancés
merci merci beaucoup à tous les quatre
d'avoir participé à cette émission on
aurait pu continuer des heures mais le
temps tourne merci en tout cas d'avoir
été là et merci à vous de nous avoir
suivi à très vite sur Public
[Musique]
Sénat